[Musique]
pour l'instant il ya du affaire conclue
chebeya du affaire conclue et j'aimerais
qu'on ait sur scène parce que les
chroniqueurs ont ramené des objets et en
1983-1984 183 première génération
minitel effectivement vous en attendez
entre 5000 et 10000 euros non non je
pense moi alors je pense que ça vaut
plus de santoro c'est super has been
quand même et c'est passé has been pour
voleurs de l'argent tant grâce à passer
comme nous 5e romanesque et soyaux est
ce que tu le cast miserait deux fils et
un bon tiger on peut faire un truc ses
responsabilités tudor 5 euros ou pas tu
gardes et comme celui de la prod avec
plaisir sans rire c'est collector c'est
une des dernières d'une série limitée il
y en a plus c'était la star d'nrj12 en
l'occurrence c'était moi les dédicaces
est désormais attendu combien j'en
attendais 100 euros peut-être donc on a
un faux 82 chez toi 0 a laissé les gens
ne connaissaient 100 000
on adore cette émission on admirateur
secret je suis comme sur cette émission
j'ai vu un admirateur secret il ya un
invité mystère ce soir puisqu'on a une
surprise pour vous derrière le rideau il
ya une personne que vous connaissez
avec qui vous avez travaillé il ya
quelques années sur la chaîne comédie
michael est avec toi applaudissements
pour michael
[Musique]
ça fait combien de temps que tu as pas
revu non ça fait longtemps est enfin
hawass a fait 20 ans et était vraiment
jamais admiré va me away j'ai en fait
j'étais ingé-son donc voilà je te
mettais les micros et et à ce moment là
que j'ai senti quelque chose quoi des de
quel côté de détient pas déjà de mon
côté et pour moi il y avait un truc
réciproque en syrie je voulais te faire
un cadeau ouais en fait je voulais te
demandé de m'épouser
comme elle prend la baguette c'est si
michel alors il faut que je te dise
quelque chose je ne suis pas célibataire
et j'ai pris un mauvais prix qui
s'appelle la fidélité à ce qu'on peut me
redonner la date d'aujourd'hui la date
de notre rencontre accusant aujourd'hui
la date et le 1er avril bob dessus c'est
un poisson d'avril
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous
le lundi 1er avril et ses touches pas
mon quotidien merci d'être avec nous
dans un instant on recevra le petit
virtuose de la flûte électronique
michel stroganoff qui sera avec nous
dans un instant michel qui reçoit un
carton hongrie qui sera avec nous bien
sûr dans quelques instants c'est la
révélation vous le savez hongroise de
flûte électronique on aura également
d'ailleurs c'est un instrument qui a
fait parler de lui j'ai entendu ou pas
par les doigts tout électrique d'abord
on aura également lé là discutera
également du break site pour la 35e
semaine et nos chroniqueurs stagiaires
bien sûr sont allés enquêter sur le très
controversé
brian fellous vient de sortir son livre
mon régime sans viande sans quoi son
sens légumes et sans eau
bref je mange des pierres et je suis
bien dans ma peau on l'aura tout à
l'heure avec les moulineaux j'ai pas de
photo de brian pelous et j'ai envie de
dire où il fait beau sur le ciel de
paris on va regarder quel temps il fait
sur la capitale quand même bien sûr on
n'a pas les images puisque nous sommes
dans touche pas à mon poste c'est pas
pour ce mobile qu'est ce qu'il faut
enfin l'animateur de légende
[Applaudissements]
les crues
la t mobile wap en ta planète du bigdil
voit très bien la basilique 10004 je
t'attends mont-saint-vincent je suis
ravi de te revoir à la télévision sur
ces 8 je suis revenu et je suis là à mon
avis je suis à rouen - quand tu veux
dans ma planète sont gay la mort fait
quand même
cali quand vincent dont le speed
mouchoirs jong il
on dirait pas comme ça mais c'est très
dur de vider une boîte de mouchoirs en
papier moi le premier qui arrive gagne
le jeu mais l'on sait qui va gagner les
poteaux moi j'ai un favori je me sur
maxime bédard est d'accord dans
exactement cinq secondes à 19h15 vous
allez monter sur les poteaux 4 3
attention et à photo kc et s'impose au
perdant je vous le dis tout de suite à
berne 3 2 contre sa mère ait accroché à
mon ventre
ah oui allez c'est l'oubli ces anciens
va glisser au dessous du poteau c'est
bien tout le monde
si à moi tu me donnes ça ils veulent que
je vous balance des balles dans la
gueule
[Musique]
les coquilles est très sensible ah
[ __ ] oh la vache de damas la série lh
je crois que je vais écouter le pompier
parce qu'il me dit que je suis resté
trop longtemps
bravo maxime joe dante leader symbolique
et messieurs merci à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]